and adele you've never lost your accent
i mean because you've been in america
for a while now yeah i've been there for
a while yeah for sure no i don't know
it's never
no
and is it true is it true that angelo
like picks you up on the way you think
he does but andro sounds just like me by
the way
yeah so obviously the whole time i've
been there he's been there and um he
goes to school with american kids and
sounds like me um
so but yeah i kind of correct him a lot
as well obviously but that's how you say
it but yeah he does on like you know the
word like free is it like the number
three oh yeah he's like it's not free
it's like three like you know he's got a
little bit more well spoken to me
probably because of his dad's but um
yeah we've both still got our accents
and you live there and obviously enjoy
living there but there must be things
you miss oh my gosh yeah i mean we
weren't supposed to live there this long
or like you know before covid we used to
spend over half our time here oh right
okay but then obviously you know i got
locked out the country with um
well if i came back here i wouldn't have
been able to get back there basically so
i was stuck there for most of kobe but
um
yeah i mean i miss like british i'm i
miss british humor i mean you know yeah
our humor is this just doesn't always
travel
so i find myself having to like explain
my jokes
ain't that much fun um but um yeah you
know i miss the humor i miss my family i
miss you know a lot of them
like my condiments and you know i love
it i love a sauce i love a sauce marmite
well mar might not quite be very but
like you know like sour cream and
branson's pickle and stuff like that you
know and um but i found a stall there
that does it all um
[Music]